Sir, how to make good notes means that time can be
managed along with it, reasoning can be done along with it.
Look, notes are very
important. What mistake do children often make? When you
read any chapter for the first time, you will
make notes at that very moment. You must have noticed it for the first time.  If
every line seems important, then I have to
say that when you read it not for the first time, but for the second or third
time, then make notes and the same notes will be of the same
size, will be less in size and will
also help in quick revision again and again and you will
also be able to get its benefit for the first time.  If you make
notes, it will be very long, it will also look
like class notes, okay, so let's follow this
method.